hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm John Humphrey we are gonna do a
fun different video request today topic
war two requests from our homeboy sir
David Gandy he said how about a video
request on the music side immediately
I'm like great now who's gonna get
blocked on YouTube and then he said you
and John can discuss a the five or so
artists whose music overall has been the
most meaningful to you be which five or
so specific songs have been the most
meaningful to you and see are there any
particular artists you believe should
have greater exposure I just picked five
as arbitrary if another number works
better for video length etc go with that
seventeen David wants us to do all each
choose whichever ones or do all three I
think he wants us to choose any amount
of them we want but each of them has to
be at least five I think it's what I'm
getting the vibe of is we can kind of
discuss as many of these as we want to
as many numeration x' as we want how
about this what if we did a little bit
of a combined where we chose how about
we just do the five songs and then we'll
see where we freestyle out from there
like the five songs that have been the
most meaningful to us as I'm sure that
out of those five some of them have to
be we need an efficient title for the
video those have to be our favorite
artists I feel like Maya there's there's
one or two songs that I have in mind to
say that I don't consider to be my
favorite artists but at least you know
three of them are I'm sure there's gonna
be some oh my god what are those called
honorable exposures yeah there's gonna
be a few exposures so yeah I guess I can
I'll kick this off
for starters this is gonna be different
this is not one of my favourite artists
but I'm just gonna say this because I
have to and because I really want to
it's safe by Bay ledges this is I don't
really talk about my personal life nor
my relationship that I've been in for
nearly three years at this point yeah
you're in a relationship with you only
three years is my girlfriend Olivia and
this song I remember before I ever told
her I loved her I heard this song on the
radio and then I I just sort of played
like I heard the song I played it was
kind of giving a little hint and now
whenever I hear it I often like I kind
of just tear up but when I'm by myself I
especially cry so that's my song my girl
it's a one little hint at our personal
life together
there you go you get to be pretty
private about it okay but yeah that
would be my number five pick damn then
I'll go with a tenderness song one of my
very favorite soft and tender jams that
is great for a lot of occasions
sometimes when the bodies hit the floor
one of us had to interrupt each other
with a stupid joke cool did not get the
respect they know there is a song that
comes to me in a lot of different
situations sometimes in for like tender
loving things sometimes in more like
soft times of grief or whatever but it's
a kind of a lullaby but by a band that I
really love so that I love when bands
switch it up and throw in something
that's kind of a curveball or that's
like dear and soft and vulnerable and
the song I'm talking about is called
good night Laura by the band spoon and
yeah it's just a really dear sweet piano
ballad that's yeah it's like a little
lullaby but it's also really beautiful
and it's also really tender and yeah
it's kind of like a warm embrace when
you need one so
yeah and you can share it with somebody
or feel embraced by the song on your own
all right could pick one of my favorite
bands as well so that's a twofer
okay so yeah this next song that I have
in mind master puppets Metallica funny
enough this is a song I don't from a
band I I generally do not like like I
generally don't like their songs cited
and their enormous band they're huge
yet every time I heard our song as I'm
like not really for me but they have one
song that sounds different from most of
theirs and I'm not sure what it is about
this like every time I listen to it and
it's a great song I think just sing
along tune it's really heartfelt and do
you know what you have an idea of who
I'm going at it's the killers all these
things that I've done oh okay yeah
that's their song right yeah one of the
most covered songs ever I don't think
it's by anybody other than the killer
but there's something that's like
Matassa up here between like all these
things that I've done and flowed on
where there's the that bit of like it's
like uplifting but also bittersweet and
melancholy at the same time and I feel
like both of those songs kind of
generate that for me and I guess there
is something about that line that you
know the catchy one I've got sold but
I'm not a soldier which just really hits
me in the fields every time like I just
love that line yeah that's a lot of
people do I don't know what he's saying
but there I've got so but I'm not a
soldier
yeah that part but yeah there's a lot of
darkness in there too time to depart
thank you I'm going to judge your list
as we go there's all personal choices
right okay so number four I debated
heavily because yeah for me there's a
lot of overlap in these different
questions but it's like tried focusing
there's a lot of overlap in terms of
like well this is a favorite artist
which would be a favorite song or
something like that so I'm the one I
thought of for this one is a song by one
of my favorite more recent discoveries
who's made like one of my desert island
albums is a guy named Frank Turner and
there are a lot of songs I really love
off his tape deck heart album but I
think the one that encompasses like a
whole breadth of his musical expression
and that also is kind of about the joy
of congregating over music and you know
dancing and singing together is a song
called four simple words which is just a
has a really great dynamic it starts off
in the sort of more acoustic territory
that he you know is more known for on a
solo level and then builds into this
full bands sort of swing in barnburner
you know and so yeah it kind of
encompasses I debated between that and a
song called telltale signs but that's a
really sad song and I feel like the
resilience that for simple words touches
on while acknowledging some of those
other feelings is really beautiful so
yeah that's another favorite artist and
a favorite song by them good choice
thanks doc oh if you made it this far
John does music video reactions on our
patreon hearing there yeah you really
knows it put on it plays guitar has
played since third grade yeah I'll never
forget
no not third grade fifth graders yeah
that's probably you start learning from
your third the third grade teachers
that's why little yeah as well it must
have been in fifth grade
I have a very specific memory yeah the
third grade teacher was my guitar
teacher yeah
your voice is traveling all throughout
the Micra this is in stereo okay so my
number three pick this might be this is
different it's not so much that this
hits me in an emotional way but I think
this song ages perfectly at least in the
last 15 or so years because this one not
really like I don't cry or something
when I hear this and doesn't it lifts me
through difficult times in a different
way it channels my imagination I've
noticed that as I as ever I grow or
wherever I do whatever I do creatively
wherever I'm at in my life
this song generates a new scene or
montage in my mind every few years like
one day I'm going to use this song in
something whatever Scorsese's connection
is to it's just a shot away by the
Rolling Stones that's in three movies of
his this is like that for me and it is
Jacqueline by Franz Ferdinand yeah I
mean I used to listen to that that the
first album just called Franz Ferdinand
which I remember her take me out when I
was in New York like 14 or 15 I came
back and you knew who the ban was and
it's like the ban John and I share and
and then yeah the song Jacqueline I have
a different kind of imagination when I
was younger I remember I used to have to
walk to work when I was like 15 and then
I would I just one time I remember
that's when we had like a just a giant
CD portable player that I just put in my
pocket big headphones I just walked in
the rain for like an hour to work and I
just listened to the whole album on a
repeat but you know like Jacqueline and
I feel like Franz Ferdinand loves that
song too because it's usually that our
opening song every concert we do for
them yeah it's like they usually kick
off the concert with that song one of
the non-single jams that still gets
everybody really riled up yeah yeah and
I feel like a lot of bands get sick of
their popular ones a vibe that they seem
to really and
brace that song yeah and yes I love that
song alright yeah see there's so many
especially now that we're recording
there's so many songs and so many
artists coming to mind that means this
is harder for you than for me yeah how
can I have rake in these how could I
have forgotten but yeah if we're keeping
plowing ahead the next song that came to
my mind is a song that actually inspired
me was one of the in my own playing to
branch out into finger based picking and
stuff like that in a big way that like
pushed me over the edge into wanting to
learn that and just noodling around that
way it's a song called word of mouth by
an artist named shakey graves who I've
come to really love in the recent years
and he's got a cool you know vibe he
kind of exists on multiple levels I mean
the first I saw him he was just his
himself with a guitar in a suitcase drum
kind of being a one-man band but he also
plays in a full you know four piece
setting and his stuff across the board
is just really unique and well lived in
and it combines a lot of genres together
and word of mouth is just a really great
sort of bluesy story song that has a
great build and is all about the walk
through life and the different people
you meet and all the bad advice that
they give you yeah and yeah it's just a
song that has so much personality and
also there's a particular performance of
it because it's never been recorded
formally like there are a lot of you can
hear it and see it a lot of places
because of the magic of the internet but
yeah there's an audio tree live
recording that he does just himself the
guitar in the suitcase drum and it's one
of my favorite performances of any song
ever so yeah word of mouth shaky graves
and for your questions see that's an
artist I wish had more exposure for sure
yeah terrific same thing for the killers
definitely man nobody's talking about
him and none of their members have
gotten to branch out beyond the killers
yes this next song got me like John into
fingering the bass with my noodle I
heard I heard a few words you said and I
was like yeah I figured that fingered
the base of my noodle
think of the baseman actually no this is
a rap song by none other
oh wait now another one really key mine
oh it's gonna hash it's gonna have to be
an honorable mention I have the other
one big honorable mentions will have 80
songs I'll mention the top 100 songs you
must listen oh okay that could be a new
perk monthly patreon playlists we trade
off months no you just curate a place so
what this this one this one's a really
depressing song and I mean it's no
mystery if you know meet some spy minam
and it's from an album people hate it
and I'm virtually not a fan of the album
either but I love this Eminem kind of
rejects this album too but I I love this
single because every single verse every
single verse and in this song every
little lyric whenever I'm in a dark
period and I feel like a lot of us go
through dark times and whenever I'm in a
dark period this is the song that I
listen to to feel understood to feel
connected you know it's like songs like
all these things that I've done is like
I'm kind of sad and bittersweet mood
whatever this is like when I'm down yeah
but to feel like someone is speaking for
mean especially with it's kind of
platform that we have where you know
it's like we got to do like reactions or
something and be like enthusiastic and
invested in it but then I have like
devastating news I got a deal with but I
don't want to that to translate over
especially at the second verse of the
song it's a Eminem's beautiful that one
I think is artistic lyrically one of his
best but yeah from just
you know there's all personal lists and
that one let's uh I will feel understood
you know like mmm could be quirky and
weird and fun and he could also be angry
and aggressive and then there's this
other side to him which is a lot softer
which end isn't surprising not as long
about Haley it's just this is one of his
softer songs about being down in the
slumps and about feeling like quitting
and yeah and I get that one that one
does a lot for me I would say Eminem's
beautiful I like that song too it's one
of the few bright spots yeah okay so for
the next one I've chosen there is a bit
of a hip-hop perspective as well not a
not completely hip-hop tune but
definitely a verse in there and it's by
also one of my favorite ex guerrillas
song called Dirty Harry which is I think
it was a single I got a music video it's
not one of their most recognizable tunes
I guess like you'd have to kind of be a
gorilla's fan to to pick up that title
probably but yeah it's got such a fun
smash collision of sounds and ideas I
mean I love that you have this sort of
children's chorus that kicks things off
in this little kind of guitar line and
then it grows into this disco thing that
later becomes this really harrowing and
very sort of relevant hip hop riff from
the perspective of a soldier and it kind
of you know it's it speaks through the
magic of what a good concept album can
do because I feel like in the Gorillaz
catalog it's like Plastic Beach is the
clearest most lucid a concept album I
would feel like diamond a is also a
concept album but I feel like there is a
little bit more coding in there and
that's a song that yeah has a lot of
relevant perspective especially about
you know like just just touching on the
ideas of war and stuff like that but
that also yeah has a really cool and
interesting smattering of sounds and
yeah that's another one of those sort of
favorite artists favorite track kind of
things I haven't bought a ringtone in
years but I'd find the other like a
month or two ago I was like
no I want Dirty Harry is my ring yeah
that's I just love that song so much so
let's get some honorable mentions out of
the way
honorable mention numero uno before I
forget it is a thrift shop not the shop
this way favorite favorite songs I'm
down I tell you but I'm feeling bad
about money Macklemore song called
starting over very different and that
okay so there's that song and then
there's other random one that is by
Immortal Technique dancer the temple
ever but I'll break it down really quick
so and with thrift shop nothing to
goddamnit I call that it starting over
you know when you copy Washington or go
get some compliments yeah we would
starting over there's a lot of things
I've had to overcome that could be
either substance abuse or or just
emotional ways I've been in my life that
I I felt like I have you know overcome
and then something comes out of me or
like a relapse into certain extent and
it's easy to get into there's a
difference in guilt and shame and the
that's that song really explores the
feeling of shame and and that that line
that he hasn't and there of oh my god
it's I don't remember perfectly right
now but if I can be an example of
getting sober I can be a greater example
of starting over because the song is
about how he like really proclaimed and
projected and showed like I'm sober and
then he relapsed and it's all this shame
but then there's also something more as
we're always gonna have to pick
ourselves back up and we're always gonna
have to restart and to in a lot of areas
and that song really explores the the
the power and willing to hit that reset
button again and
again and again until you keep you know
you just got to keep going and and then
[Laughter]
that song really clicks I don't connect
with that song but that was the first
rap song I've heard that was really
painting a full-on story it's a nearly
10 minute song and it goes down some
really disturbed twisted ways it's told
in a linear way there's nothing really
mystique about it it has to be fiction
and then that though the ability to it's
like I've never lost in that story it's
like I was I was really impressed with a
song that truly paints a straightforward
narrative and they go [ __ ] dark and
then ain't no a couple and then the that
makes me think of one we probably share
unless it's your first one another story
song why what's your stories huh it's by
a band that we both like and I know it's
a song we both love and its first word
is a state state is is a state in the
Union you know there's a north and a
south I'll just say it's Carolina drama
oh yeah that's a great one that would be
a runner-up for me fo damn that's a
great story I've always wanted to make
the music something so powerful about it
not having a music video ruin it if it
did but I would want to make that's a
good one my my other one is um I wanted
to say a boy named Sue by Johnny Cash
I'm wearing a Johnny Cash Rose I got a I
got to mention it but Johnny Cash is a
special place in my heart because my dad
was obsessed with Johnny Cash introduced
me to him walk the line came out
suddenly everyone loves Johnny casual
like people my age were really into
Johnny Cash and a lot of people got into
Johnny Cash at my age around the time
that happened
and then PI near the fandom for
something I'm just saying so but I would
actually say the song cry cry cry B and
it's not really because of the lyrics
they I'll actually funny enough a lot
factors into the movie I don't know what
happened in the first recording studio I
don't know what I don't think that's
what happened where he formed the
perfect band my little well but you have
shaken my faith in the Jewish people but
there was that moment that scene really
helped at a at an early age show me what
was different about Johnny Cash in his
time of being told like you're doing
like you're just trying to do the same
yada yada you gospel stuff that everyone
else is doing seeing something from the
heart and and then he show he shows off
this like dark expression it's song and
it's easy to hear song like cry cry cry
still viewed as this a catchy country
tune when when you're listening to
lyrics it's a pretty mess though song
and Anna and so I would say cry cry cry
by Johnny Cash because I like the
different renditions people do of it and
adults and also like I've always wanted
to hear it kind of like a slower
build-up version of that song there's a
lot of Johnny Cash long as I got
actually list but I'm gonna go with that
one yeah and we'll stop there because
John what's number 100 just a few I'll
keep it I'll try and limit myself
another one of my favorite bands is
Silversun Pickups and they have a song
called the three seed on their first
album that's one of my all-time favorite
songs just really beautiful and textural
and poetic and stuff there's also a song
on another one there oblems called catch
and release I don't know they have songs
I love throughout their discography but
um yeah those two come to mind Feist
does a song called get not high get not
low that I really love
recently desert sessions something you
can't see with the lead singer from the
Scissor Sisters and AWOL Nations a band
that I love and sail oddly enough like
there are so many songs I could choose
from and I only choose sail because it's
one of the few singles ever
that I remember the first time I heard
it and every time I've heard it since I
still get the same feeling and it hasn't
ever diminished or dissipated and
they're a band that I love to see I love
every time they come back with new tunes
and stuff also stop that train biola
nation is a great more recent cut and
I'm sure there are a million more that
could come to mind uh uh little Sims 101
FM is another one and she's a rapper who
I really hope more people discover
because her just the musical palette she
works in are amazing and her personality
on the mic and her writing is fantastic
and yeah I just hope people don't sleep
on her and I guess I'll segue out of my
honorable mentions because I don't have
much on my mind I'm surprised didn't say
any of modest mouse oh man what would be
a fail yeah it's yes I would have to
zoom in on a specific song and that's
the hard part it's like they're
definitely one of my favorite bands
they're like Franz Ferdinand is one of
my favorite bands Outsiders is I guess
if I had to choose like an honorable
mention favorite from their second album
that's uh that's what France or the tot
area mix of stand on the horizon those
to your favorites I would say Han
Springs by the white stripes I also
really love this this is a song that I
wish was see most of the music I listen
to
I'm not I really listen to most of the
music that I for imagination purposes I
love to just kind of escape into my
imagination with those songs there were
some people that like really listen to
the music and get lost in and imagine I
don't know what they really imagined but
I'm usually like imagining scenes in the
story or something that's usually where
my mind is going and the modest mouse
song still in the honorable mention the
modest mouse song I would say that I
really wish was in a movie and it just
seems like it's made for movies is satin
in a coffin oh yeah that's a great one
that would be a runner-up in like Queens
of the Stone Age is like
burn the witch I was gonna say mosquito
song I was gonna say that one burn the
witch definitely but not a smell so
thrown marching to the CEO of that song
very much I mean we give you a whole
probably list of yeah on to number one
the number one pick this is if anyone
knows me this is my favorite band of all
time and this is probably their most
popular single of all time and it was my
introduction into them and this was
something that I this kind of
encompasses everything I've been talking
about from all my pics of feeling that
bitter sweetness the darkness but also
feeling like there's light at the end of
the tunnel and picking yourself back up
like everything I've been talking about
it doesn't really channel my imagination
and that's the funny thing about Red Hot
Chili Peppers is I don't really imagine
scenes with these guys but yet like
they're the only band where when I
listen to them I'm just listening and
they're the only band that does that for
me they have a few songs where my
imagination goes but most of the time no
I'm just enamored and and you know the
swirling and all all the players and it
is under the bridge like that just
encompasses everything for me I would go
I used to have to take the subway
everywhere I went and or go wait at bus
stops and I was constantly just
listening to that song as a kid and just
in the dark place but it still has the
same effect and I also think from just a
musical standpoint I'm kind of surprised
by how famous of a song it is
considering that it's so not traditional
in the structure of the song I know some
of our biggest songs like free bird or
stairway to heaven or not you know a
traditionally structured like this has a
weird structure to it when you break it
down but it doesn't seem odd or out of
place
it really works and
I always feel the chorus when he's you
know I think we each have our own
Anthony Kiedis voice but yeah what's I
would say that one alright then I guess
we'll move on to the shouts out dr.
mastodons the sparrow and the last baron
cuz those are two pretty amazing songs
as well and just to Linkin Park because
they were like I was my first Linkin
Park my first favourite band back in the
day and I've always kept up with them
like I like all their albums to some
degree and I just felt like I need to
shout them out a lot live in Texas is my
favorite live album I saw that in the
theaters my mom took me and she dug it
to know that that's like easily my
favorite live album yeah man it's hard
it's hard to pick from like whoa be my
favorite and have room there's but and
yeah I was definitely in glad you
brought them up yeah yeah there's
there's a lot but I yeah my number one
it's weird I'm very indecisive in this
life and when it comes to choosing
favorites like when it comes to making a
list I always struggle and yet weirdly I
know what my favorite movie and my
favorite song are which surprises me but
you actually already named checked it
and it's a song as well yeah yeah that's
a song by my very favorite band by my
very favorite band is yeah Queens of the
Stone Age mosquito song there was
something about the way when I said it
of how you reacted very favorite song I
remember it's weird it's like I didn't
even fully understand it the first time
I heard it cuz you know I was like 12
and that came out but um I don't know
there's something so inherently cheeky
to me about the fact that it is a hidden
track except for it's listed on the back
of the album as the hidden track which
I've always found very funny but um yeah
that's just that song especially after
the journey that songs for the Deaf is
is this wonderfully cinematic strange
dark beautiful story song coda thing and
it's one of those songs that really
makes me see colors and think of imagery
and that's the song we're like I want to
make that music video
I want to make my six minutes film out
of this song because yeah it has it's
it's josh is singing it in a voice that
doesn't even sound like his natural
voice which I love this sort of
otherworldly quality about the vocals I
love these sort of intricate and soft
acoustic lines and then the song gives
way part way through to this big
orchestral interlude that just has so
much aura and atmosphere and actually
one of the lines in that song went on to
name their next album which was
lullabies to paralyze so yeah that's
just a song I thought it was from that
album because of that and then yeah the
next album pulled that lyrics oh yeah I
don't know for whatever reason ever
since that album came out and even
before I learned truly to listen to
albums in album format that was a song
that always held my ear and that one of
these days I'm gonna learn how to play
that that song I always thought could be
like a perf like no audio on-screen but
like the final moments of like some
montage wrap-up of a character's descent
yeah something like that weird sort of
it's not a sad song but it has that
melancholic sort of twisted softness
yeah yeah I always imagined like some
guy who's like embraced his darkness who
is beyond saving or yeah and it's always
comes to mind with that song it's
someone who's like kinda has a sinister
smile about it all oh yeah yeah and then
before you wrap up this video spoons
they want my soul and right on
Frankenstein by death from above 1979
okay I'm gonna stop naming songs yeah
Queens don't age that's my all-time
favorite yeah yeah I just want to shout
out ooh I just got a shout this person
out Corey Feldman
Britany speakers oh yeah you can't oh I
totally overlooked that I still don't
know why I love her song so much but I
really [ __ ] do there's not a would
like what is there's the most commercial
kind of songs you can think of the man I
just can work out to her song as I can
chive on the road like I their kid it
was a great karaoke song yeah there's a
reason she's a pop sensation she is the
Super's the heart she's not the greatest
singer she's not a very good dancer but
man but when she's got a group around
her and the songs yeah like her voice is
just perfect enough well you know it's
that thing where it where your voice is
perfect for your music
I've never beauty of not being on
Broadway I've never heard a song from
her that I was like wow not even lucky
not even luck this is a song about a
girl named Lucky she's so lucky she's a
star one day I'm gonna read to a
children's group anyway David thanks for
requesting this is fun David it's fun
talk about music
John isn't really gonna talk about as
much so glad we could do this yeah I
don't you know who doesn't really listen
to music
Tyron Magnus he's not a music guy yeah
it's kind of weird it's like hearing
someone who's like I don't like comedy
you know it's like I've heard like one
or two people say I'm like that's a
weird sentence like like he likes music
but I like audio of stuff you know oh
yeah listen to music but I feel like
music connects to all of us and it says
it's it's it's great universal language
has more repeat value than any movie or
show
five maybe 12 David hey I just want to
say I'm happy Thanksgiving to you
brother you've been an amazing soul in
our life and I know you rock out at the
church you play your own tunes you're
killing it in martial arts find a way to
combine the two martial arts music I
feel like you should write a song about
overcoming cancer David was like one of
the first people to hit me real
emotional in that way of like he hit us
up saying that he like what helped get
him through the cancer stages was like
with the treatment and stuff was
actually watching our videos and that
always like dawned on me of like oh they
were that good really more emotion
waking up early and watching trailers
but there's always stood out to me of
like that's such a it's create some
weird like existential thought-provoking
it doesn't not everything has to be like
huge and earth-shattering to be
important like Britney like beers [ __ ]
thank you David for being you
I hope you and your dad have a good
Thanksgiving and get your ass stuff I
don't mean that in a suggestive way I'm
in a taxidermy way get it stuff once
you're overcome colon cancer so maybe
you should get a hydro colonic cleanse
I'm room safe for all that digestion the
Urich about to undergo you should do it
before Thanksgiving if you can thanks
Dave